am vergangenen samstag explodierte im
moskauer mächtigen und reichen viertel
ein auto am steuer die russin daria
dugena das attentat befeuert die
gerüchteküche dugena ist die tochter des
rechtsgerichteten ideologen alexander
dugin seit jahren propagiert du gehen
ein großes russisches reich und auch
krieg gegen die ukraine russlands
geheimdienst beschuldigt die ukraine für
das attentat verantwortlich zu sein über
ein halbes jahr krieg aber auch über
diesen mysteriösen anschlag treten wir
gleich mit einer expertin zuvor die
wichtigsten zusammenhänge von andreas
künast
es sind noch keine 48 stunden vergangen
da steht im russischen staatsfernsehen
alles fest die mörder von daria dugena
sind ermittelt es war eine operation
ukrainischer geheimdienste
dann zeigt die sendung noch einmal die
sekunden nach dem anschlag das zerfetzte
auto der 29-jährigen das entsetzen im
gesicht ihres vaters der rechtsnationale
ideologe alexander dugin damit seiner
tochter auf dem heimweg von einer
veranstaltung ob original oder ob der
vater oder beide das ziel dieses
anschlags waren das kann man im moment
nicht beurteilen daria dugena galt als
fanatische befürworterin des angriffs
auf die ukraine sie riefen zur tötung
ihrer bewohner auf ukraine sein um
menschen ihr vater alexander dugin ist
ein ultra nationalistische publizist der
den westen verachtet und die östliche
zivilisation als überlegen betrachtet
eine in russland völlig unbekannte
gruppe die so genannte nationale
republikanische armee bekennt sich zu
dem anschlag
aber niemand kennt sie
also ich habe noch nie davon gehört ich
beschäftige mich seit 25 jahren mit mit
russland und dem postsowjetischen raum
also es ist sehr stark
verschwörungstheoretiker der russische
geheimdienst präsentiert diese
attentäterin was der fsb über sie an
videos fotos infos verbreitet klingt aus
moskauer sicht perfekt die 43 jährige
ist angeblich ukrainerin angeblich
mitglied des regiments der angebliche
ausweis passt die angebliche flucht nach
estland passt manchen passt es ein
bisschen zu gut das ist doch sehr
erstaunlich dass in diesem überwachten
moskau die kameras mal wieder nicht
funktioniert haben als dieser mord
passiert ist und das dann innerhalb von
wenigen stunden
ukrainische täterin vom fsb
identifiziert worden ist eine weitere
anschuldigung gegen die ukraine weitere
rufe nach rache eine weitere
verschärfung des konflikts
sarah packung ist bei uns sie ist von
der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik russland expertin
stimmung
also dieses update ist ein mysteriöses
und da drängt sich schon die frage auf
wer profitiert von so einem attentat auf
den ersten blick erst einmal keiner auf
der fsb scheint mir hier nicht die
naheliegende lösung zu sein sondern am
ende muss er sich ja auch die frage
stellen warum er das zugelassen hat wenn
es so offensichtlich war dass diese frau
ja mit auf videos durch die gegend
gefahren ist die andere frage ist
inwiefern es noch mal zu einem erstarken
auch das rechten nationalistischen
lagers führt darauf jetzt aber wirklich
theorien abzuleiten wer daran
verantwortlich scheint mir da relativ
dünn von der beweislage also die rufe
nach rache aktionen die liest man schon
im netz könnte jetzt dieses attentat
dazu führen dass russland
vergeltungsmaßnahmen durchführende die
frage ist natürlich dann gegen wen wenn
es eben so ist dass russland die ukraine
verantwortlich macht müssen wir sagen
man führt ohnehin schon einen sehr
brutalen krieg auch mit sehr starken
menschenrechtsverletzungen dort also
dass die frage inwiefern man das noch
bräuchte und da jetzt wirklich mal
weitere maßnahmen zu rechtfertigen also
es ist noch ziemlich schwer dazu auch
stellung zu beziehen weil eben so vieles
unklar ist und man einfach zu wenig weiß
darum muss man jetzt eigentlich auch
nicht weiter spekulieren
morgen ist ein
spezielles datum sechs monate
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine wenn sie
sie haben diesen 24 februar ja auch
erlebnis hier her was für eine bilanz
ziehen sie
eine würde ich sagen am ende doch sehr
überraschen also was wir von russischer
seite gesehen haben ist dass man
eigentlich in einem wesentlichen kriegs
zielen die man ja versucht hat
kurzfristig zu erreichen gescheitert ist
also sowohl die einnahme kias als auch
ein regime change und das einzige was
man eigentlich verbuchen kann ist die
eroberung große teile der ost ukraine
und ein jetzt ja auch durchaus
wieder unter beschuss geraten ist ein
teil der judoka ihnen also das ist eben
eine sehr durchwachsene bilanz nicht
dass du trotzdem ist es natürlich so
dass die bilanz dieses krieges
katastrophales mit 10.000 toten sehr
vielen zivilen opfern sehr vielen
ukrainerinnen und kreieren die auf der
flucht sind also sicherlich eine
humanitäre katastrophe die
erschüttert nach einem halben jahr was
nach einigen tagen des 24 februars
deutlich wurde war so eine sehr stark
betonte einigkeit des westens die nato
steht zusammen die bündnispartner stehen
zusammen das wurde so nach einigen
monaten also vor einigen wochen ging das
ja los abgelöst von
ja so erschütterungen müssen wir
eigentlich weiter sanktionen verhängen
es geht jetzt um unsere energie um
unsere krise wie deuten sie das also das
ist eigentlich nicht überraschen wir
merken jetzt natürlich dass dieser krieg
ein auswirkungen auch auf uns hat nicht
nur durch die sanktionen sondern ist es
die strategie von putin ja natürlich ist
dass die strategie von putin also wenn
wir darauf schauen welches kalkül mal in
moskau hat dann geht man einfach davon
aus dass moskau am ende den längeren
atem hat sei es wegen der energiepreise
oder andere wirtschaftlicher und
politischer nachteile und dass man
einfach darauf hofft dass die westliche
unterstützung für die ukraine weiter
nachlassen wird und man dann eben in der
ukraine auch die oberhand gewinnen kann
man fragt sich natürlich wie lange ist
das eigentlich durchzuhalten
die einen sagen das geht jetzt noch
jahre so weil das konto russlands
einfach so prall gefülltes durch die
ganzen energie einnahmen wie lange kann
russland dieser art von krieg noch
aufrecht erhalten und diese isolation
vorantreiben ich fürchte sehr lange dann
auch wenn wir uns anschauen wie russland
auch in vergangenen kriegen vorgegangen
ist ist es immer so dass das politische
kalkül wichtiger ist als das
wirtschaftliche also man strebt eben
keine wirtschaftlich prosperierende
nation an sondern an imperialen start
und dafür ist nun eben auch bereit große
wirtschaftliche auch große menschliche
opfer zu bringen das würde ich sagen
dass wir damit rechnen müssen dass es
noch lange so weitergehen kann ja das
sind düstere aussichten erfahrung von
der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik danke dass j morgen
hier bei uns war gerne